bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'elle gl j'ai fait parler de lui en
rumeur par rapport à un nouveau produit
qui va arriver
le lg 7 lg qui a des produits qui sont
vraiment cool vraiment sexy et ça on va
en parler on va faire un petit portrait
robot dieu g7 voir quand est-ce qu'ils
devraient sortir
est-ce qu'il sera intéressant à qui va
destiner quelqu'un pourra retrouver dans
toutes les rumeurs tous les potins au
regard de sa maman
[Musique]
lg revenu en forme dans le game l'année
dernière avec le lgv 30 début 2018 on a
vu au mwc à barcelone le lgv 30 think
you là on vient trouver le lg 7 pourquoi
pas un lg g7 think you ça me paraît
plutôt logique parce que le côté think
you c'est l'intelligence artificielle
c'est la reconnaissance de celle c'est
vraiment le produit intelligence et du
point de vue logiciel 1 du point de vue
matériel
il ya une petite différence tout cas il
y avait sur le v30 là sur le g7 on va
avoir un produit directement fink ue
donc ça devrait être plutôt cool
un produit qui sera annoncée au mois
d'avril pour être commercialisé dès le
mois de mai à savoir que lg aurait
questionné ses consommateurs n'y a pas
très longtemps sur reddit pour savoir
s'il aimait les encoches oui ou non s'il
voulait le désencrage oui ou non les
réponses ont été dithyrambiques n'ont
quasiment non pour tout le monde
on ne veut pas de set en poche on n'aime
pas les encoches c'est vrai que c'est
quand même un truc qui partagent
énormément parce que depuis qu'apple a
démocratisé l'encoche grand public avec
son iphone 10
on voit que de plus en plus de
constructeurs android se met à coller
des encoches à droite à gauche
probablement pour avoir deux plus grands
écrans pour pouvoir utiliser au maximum
puis de l'écran autant apple l'a fait
ils ont quand même vendu des iphone 10
se sont pas trop les gens donc nous
aussi on va le faire
et puis ça peut être très intéressant à
terme donc lg à questionner directement
sur reddit et a supprimé le poste très
très très peu de temps après escalier
sortie c'était un nom assez générales
donc ce qui sortirait a priori ce que je
ferai ça serait quand même d'intégrer
une encoche mais en proposant au point
de vue logiciel de la cacher c'est à
dire que vous auriez le choix d'utiliser
l'encoche ou de ne pas l'utiliser à des
fins esthétiques donc là un peu ils
prennent pas de positions vis bien vos e
mails en col je vous la mettez vous
voulez mais pas vous la mettez pas nous
le propose comme ça personne ne se fâche
il tranche pas sur le modèle réellement
mais de l'autre côté il se mouille pas
trop non plus alors que te design cette
vraie 30 produits auprès de ce qu'on
nomme aujourd'hui des différents des
différentes rumeurs qui circulent en
produits qui seraient plutôt pas mal
réussi avec des bords en métal avec un
dos en verre qui pourrait permettre la
recharge par induction la présence d'un
port jack une recharge via une prise usb
type co2 un double capteur photo
centrale à la verticale est en dessous
un lecteur d'empreintes digitales
alors vous devriez avoir quatre boutons
sur ce produit trois à gauche le bouton
de volume pour le monter pour le bc un
bouton pour l'allumer 1 pour l'éteindre
et un bouton son côté droit on pourrait
penser a priori que ce bout
on serait dédiée à l'intelligence
artificielle alors il faut savoir que
les produits lg travaille avec google
assistant ils ont pas à leurs solutions
de datacert et fils y el dédié
directement à lg google assistant
fonctionne vraiment bien donc
globalement n'y a pas de robin avec on
n'imagine pas que ce soit un bouton pour
faire des photos comment retrouver sur
des produits de sony mais plutôt
vraiment un bouton dédié à
l'intelligence artificielle d'où le nom
lg g7 thank you et là où effectivement
il va y avoir du changement par rapport
aux ong des 30 c l'écran on aura un
écran de 6,1 pouces mais on n'aurait pas
un écran oled tout simplement pour une
question de coût pour proposer un tarif
abordable par rapport à la concurrence
on devrait avoir un écran mlcd alors on
aurait des pixels blancs en plus du r
gbr gbc red green blue rouge vert bleu 1
pour ceux qui ne parlent pas anglais
je sais vous parlait quasiment tous
anglais mais je le précise et des pixels
blancs qui vont venir ajouter plus de
luminosité donc un écran qui serait
beaucoup plus lumineux et forcément
beaucoup moins coûteux pour lg en écran
qui consommerait beaucoup moins en
termes de batterie que permettrait
d'avoir une plus grande longévité au
niveau de la batterie
alors tout ça bien évidemment cela
prendre avec des pincettes
on sait que lg fabrique ses écrans oled
ses propres écrans oled donc cette
techno pour être très intéressante
uniquement pour proposer un produit
beaucoup moins cher à l'arrière on
devrait avoir une double caméra 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
1.5 pourquoi f1 points 5 pourrait
concurrencer un petit peu les
photophones de cette année les samsung
galaxy s 9 et un snuff plus on ouverture
variable est au plus bas
ils descendent jusqu'à f 1.5 pour capter
plus de luminosité et en termes de
luminosité le wei wei p20 pro va aussi
jusqu'à f 1.5 donc on va très bien que
lg vient épauler marché sur ce terrain
ils savent très bien que de toute façon
ils sont pas forcément dans le top 3 des
meilleurs vendeurs de smartphones de
niveau mondial mais il va venir
grignoter un peu des parts de marché
pour vendre ce produit et essayer de le
positionner donc l'idée d'avoir un
photophone qui devrait être en tout cas
sur le papier plutôt séduisant c'est
bien lors sa blessure on reverra plus
tard c'est un produit contestera
ensemble et on regardera si
effectivement il est intéressant en
termes de photos par rapport au s 9 s9
plus et par rapport au p 20 pro donc
rester connecté parce que ces produits
on va bientôt aller tester ensemble
côté processeur on devrait avoir une
bête de compet le qualcomm snapdragon
845 et on devrait avoir deux versions
alors soit le g7 quelques gigas de ram
64 giga de stockage soit le g7 + 6
gigaoctets de ram 128 giga de stockage
bon dans les deux cas ça devrait quand
même plutôt bien fonctionné on aurait
des hauts parleurs stéréo une
certification ip68 résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière et un tarif qu'on nous
annonce est raisonnable pour être
compétitif
un tarif situé entre 700 à 750 euros
pour celle de samsung galaxy s neuf se
vend 1 859 euros
le p 20 euros on est pareil au sud et
800 euros là on se positionne un peu en
dessous est ce que d'un autre côté le
delta entre 700 et 750 euros suffirait à
ce que des personnes switch de ces
grosses marques pour aller chez lg
lg fonctionne très bien c'est une très
grande marque mais qui est quand même
beaucoup moins forte que ses concurrents
apple samsung et huawei en terme de
téléphonie mobile donc là on voit très
bien que le défi pour lg ce très
clairement c'est de gagner des parts de
marché pour essayer de se positionner
toujours mieux en terme de ventes de
smartphones ils seront probablement pas
le photophone de cette année mais en
attendant en allant avec un double
capteur arrière 16 mégapixels et une
ouverture de f 1.5 voir sur dans
l'hypothétique un rennais a été
confirmée par le constructeur mais c'est
des choses qu'on pourrait effectivement
trouvé ça permettrait à alger de se
positionner comme ayant un excellent
photophone en 2018 est d'autant plus une
machine couplet avec de l'intelligence
artificielle qui fait partie aussi des
standards qu'on trouve cette année
effectivement un teaser officiel on peut
la regretter chez samsung qui pourtant
est le numéro de numéro un mondial avec
apple en a un petit peu là la première
place parce que bixby pour l'instant
n'est toujours pas en français
d'ailleurs la xb 2 qui devrait arriver
probablement sur le galaxy note 9
mais c'est vrai que c'est un truc de
dingue parce que aujourd'hui samsung
n'est toujours pas au point avec son
intelligence artificielle bixby pourtant
annoncé il ya un peu plus d'un an et a
contrario lg fonctionne bien avec google
assistant nombreux à les comprendre le
truc bon et pour nous d'un point du
consommateur c'est quoi l'intérêt est
bien dans la mesure où elle fabrique de
bon smartphone qui fonctionne plutôt
bien
le sgv 30 est un bon produit moi j'ai
jamais rien eu à lui reprocher lgv 30
think you je détestais mais je n'ai pas
eu plus longtemps que ça dans les mains
c'est jamais plus qu'un lgv 30 boosté à
l'intelligence artificielle avec un
petit peu plus de performance bon si
sensiblement la même machine de toute
façon mais l'intérêt pour le
consommateur d'abord un g7 un g7 plus
c'est vraiment de se dire qu'on a un
produit qui va coûter moins cher
hier que la concurrence mais qui
fonctionnera très bien sans aucun
problème sur android avec un google
assistant d'ailleurs dites moi ce que
vous en pensez à ce que vous avez déjà
vu des produits de lg est ce que ça
pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que pourriez est ce que vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter par ce lg
c'est tel que nous le décrit aujourd'hui
mark et moi tout ça en commentaire bien
évidemment comme d'hab vous laissez des
jolies pouces vous invite à vous abonner
parce qu'on parlait toujours plus et
toujours mieux de technologie avec plein
de choses des bonnes surprises qui vont
arriver donc restez connectés d'ici là
portez vous bien soyez sages
je vous embrasse je vous dis à très
bientôt et surtout restez connectés
yahoo